ich war schon zweimal auf höhen an
compilation reagieren gesamt haben die
videos sogar vier millionen aufrufe
gesammelt weiter von wurden geklemmt
aber okay aber ich habe etwas neues
entdeckt meine damen und herren es hat
wieder etwas mit dem tod
wir sind cool wir starten nicht bei der
einzelnen bei der 5 wir klicken einfach
mal auf play und den schon dort fährt
jemand mit seinem auto ganz normalen
ceylan über den freeway und sehen
da kommt ihm gerade so ein scheit
anhänger entgegen irgendwie ist er
wahrscheinlich bei dem lkw ab gegangen
oder sich nicht immer wieder auf play
und richtig eng ausgewiesen
zwischen
ausgewichen und leute bleibt unbedingt
bis zum ende des videos dran weil da
kommen noch zwei kranke sache hier steht
jemand auf einem berg und er will
anscheinend darüber springen glaube ich
mal wieso macht man das überhaupt lässt
das lockende brücke darüber zukommen er
steht also zögert noch ein wenig und o
wow
als ich jetzt so was von die krise
gekriegt beim zugucken ist wichtig ist
aber auch wenn ich unfälle oder auch zu
machen wo sich leute wehtun ich immer
angst keine ahnung was okay er lag nur
auf werte zwischen ebene hier geht jetzt
wieder hoch mit meinem kollegen und
jetzt haben wir wieder eine sache von
dem freeway wahrscheinlich wieder einen
hänger der irgendwie in blauer alter
schwede
pikant wird dumm sein und überholen wenn
da gegenverkehr kommt man jetzt freie
fahrbahn und jetzt überholte typ da
hinten einfach nur etwas was fällt ihm
ein mann ich weiß nicht was man hier
sieht aber wahrscheinlich ja genau hier
eine bahn daten bestehe so ist das der
nennwerte des compilations kann sein
dass verwirklich einer gestorbenen mann
ich dachte die ganze zeit hinten dass
der lkw jetzt noch gerade wo drüberfährt
über die gleise der zug dann halt ganz
nah dran vorbei aber wenn du ok drücken
sie mir einfach wertvolle kanada ein
paar sekunden später leute achtet mal
hier vorne auf den typen ich glaube
jetzt wieder mal ran und genau das
schiff märkte da hinten ist der typ der
läuft jetzt gerade noch weg von dem lkw
montiert wird der rest weggezogen
deswegen war mir zu des compilation oder
was mit dem zug fahren so ziert das weiß
man ja nicht hier sehen wir wieder eine
autodesk irgendwo in amerika erfährt
über die die leute drüber und noch mal
über die gleitet man sieht aber noch
nichts da hinten bränden schon alle ich
weiß nicht was da jetzt passieren so
adam watch hier also da laufen jetzt
wahrscheinlich leute über die kreuzung
genau und der
alter schwede war todes hängen versuch
mal genau in dem moment stoppen wo man
das nicht und zwar am
ja aber das passiert in köln sicher
jeden tag hier haben wir jemanden der
klettert und der wird die ganze vom
wasser angesetzt jetzt kettet sein
kollege runter oder dergleichen bisschen
früher oder so keine ahnung
seit sich auf jeden fall auch an dem
berg ab ich verstehe nicht wie man an
seinem witzigen berg einfach klettern
kann erklärt irgendwo sicher so kathrin
aehnlich immer sicher
ist das jetzt hier in plate mit seinen
kanal drahtgitter mit den vorgespult und
hier steht michael borth ver di-vize
bade mal 17 meter
dann sehen wir hier eine perfekte welt
hat ihre politik gewollt aus wasser
nicht gewollt außerdem ist
heruntergefallen ist aber ich glaube
dass mir das sage ich glaube dass mehr
oder weniger nichts passiere daten
blutiges knie ich mein knie war peter
groh also das ist ein akku und einfach
gut drauf ich hab's trotzdem lieber
erzählt wird jetzt im schnitt weil
youtube ich schon mit dem hartplatz in
sachen angeht hier wird in einem
taktisch sind zwar drei war
oscar-preisträger es impressionen
offered rate also fährt er jetzt in
seinem taxi rom und jetzt wurde
wahrscheinlich von einem typen die
angeklagten wurden fragen gestellt
erhält er jetzt an und bekommen fragen
gestellt und jetzt holt er irgendwie
eine waffe raus oder irgendwie nippel
oder eben die wahl und ich bin halt
gespannt also ich glaube es wird jetzt
dagegen sein dass er sich irgendwie zu
ihm ins auto setzen oder so etwas tut es
destruction of the drivers and complex
games
die driver's ort
das heißt diese personen direkt am rand
stand und ihm fragen gestellt hat war
nur so eine art verwirrung ablenkung
wort er war weil sein kollege dann von
einer seite kamen auf ihn geschossen
hätte jetzt sehen wir halten noch wer
wegfährt und total wie ich möchte
überhaupt nicht klar kommen auch mein
leben wenn leute auch nicht angefangen
zu schießen
driver die zeit bevor die politische
linke die polizei anruft und das war's
dann auch schon hier mehr oder weniger
von dem video also dass sich jetzt nur
noch irgendwie hier unten verändert ja
die leute werden alle mal fast gestorben
schreibt ihr doch auch mal in die
kommentare ob ihr schon gegen welche
erfahrungen hast oder irgendwie sowas
also wo ihr euch wirklich gedacht hätte
tot dann finde ich sagen wenn euch das
video gefallen hat und die eventuell
nochmal wollte reagiere dann lasse ich
nichts aber freunde findet jetzt hier
oben eine 2 die eingeblendete da
draufdrücken main kanal kostenlos
abonnieren bietet auch einen schock
eingeblendet in dem man unter anderem
dieses t shirt hier gibt und hier unten
ist ein jahr leute hätten schon fast
gedacht ein anderes video verlinkt
könnte es auch angucken aber erstmal
kanal abonnieren